they think you can't get social media
wrong you put something out there and
the world loves it clearly that is not
what happened for justine sacco door
deacon but if you work for anyone
you're no your voice you're not an
individual it reflects your entire
company how did this go so drastically
wrong what should have been done well
what went wrong was somebody said
something ridiculously awful and so I
actually take a totally different spin
on this I see and everybody who's
watching that's worried about their
company and their employees doing the
wrong thing does anybody really think
that IEC is in big trouble or any of
their customers are gonna stop working
with them absolutely not
just Dean's got a problem everybody
watching who's a human being forget
about your job what about your legacy
this woman's children
great-grandchildren everybody on earth
this is her face to the world so I'm
much more worried about legacy than jobs
there's no big corporation that's going
to lose a ton of business off an
employee saying something silly because
let's call it what it is there's a ton
of ridiculous stuff being said every
single day healings are flawed we just
have tools now to show how flawed we
really are then Garry helped us
understand how to use social media
correctly you are someone who puts
themselves out there not just in their
visits you give your opinion there's a
huge risk in doing that I think intent
matters you know I think what happened
here was you could look back at the
history of what she said and there was a
lot of questionable comments through the
years for me I'm not scared to share my
opinions because my intent is never
wrong
right I may make a mistake but I think
intent is what the driving force behind
this is and then you know back to the
title the book give-give given and asked
I think the biggest problem right now at
least from a brand standpoint you know
for the CEOs and CMOS that are watching
this right now for their organizations
they're not giving enough to their
audience it's all about themselves
buy my book buy my stop watch my show
it's all me me me it's all right hook
right hook right hook and when you know
a right hooks coming you're going to
duck all right Gary let's assume you've
got a virtual PhD in social media how
did you get it what is your story you
know my story is unique in the fact that
I'm an immigrant I was born in Russia I
came to the US my dad had a liquor store
and I grew up in the liquor store I
would tell you that
I learned what I learned about social
media by working the floor of my dad's
liquor store how easy all I ever do on
social media or in life or even right
now what's going on with all the people
in this room all I'm really watching is
people's behavior I watched how people
walked around the store what they
reacted to it's really salesmanship it's
really psychology and so all I try to do
is think about how do people become
liked in real life and that's what I try
to project on social then how do you
figure out on social what's authentic
and what's not I am sure with a million
followers every day you get people
tweeting at you follow me back Gary what
do you think about the Jets what's real
how did you get your authentic voice out
there I think everything actually is
real I'm not worried about getting got
right like I'm not worried at me meaning
I'm not worried about putting time into
people that have only the intent to sell
me something or only the intent to use
me to get to somebody else because I
actually think there's enormous leverage
in giving first I think the biggest
problem right now in society let alone
the brands that I'm consulting for that
are working on social the whole media
world is that everybody wants things
very quickly and more importantly are
fearful of giving without getting to me
the leverage of giving first is how I
got my voice is why I have results I'm
not worried if I give give give and I
don't get when you when you eliminate
entitlement you create enormous leverage
so when GE picks up the phone and says
I'm going to call this Russian kid I've
learned his skills walking the floor of
a liquor store
what is that conversation and what do
you do for a company like GE you know I
mean in 2009 my brother AJ and I started
vaynermedia and it was because a lot of
brands were coming to me and they were
asking me why do you have all these
followers on all these platforms and
we're big global brands and we don't
have anywhere close to that
and so the GE conversation had a couple
years in after we started working with
PepsiCo and Campbell's and the NHL so it
wasn't that rogue of a conversation what
we do for GE or any other brand we work
with whether it's Unilever or the the
Jets it's we asked them a very simple
question it's fun to like talk about it
here in the context of this it's
business what do you want to accomplish
and then
decide whether Facebook Twitter Tumblr
Pinterest Instagram snapchat vine
whatever they're trying to accomplish
which of the platforms can we accomplish
that on and then let's put out content
slash campaigns that drive that business
objective all right you say snapchat I
dog on snapchat all the time saying a
three billion you didn't snap Jack
didn't want to salt so for three and
half billion dollars to Facebook I look
at it and say this is a this is an app
for sexting you disagree yes and that
for sexting is what old white male media
decided to label on snack Gary Vee just
called me old white male media it is
about a high birthday everybody I accept
all right now all right talk to me who's
he is a GE gonna use snapchat it's so
it's skewing young right if I'm a brand
that's trying to court 16 to 25 year
olds in any shape or form you need to be
on snapchat and the reason snapchat
works is because it actually grabs your
attention while you're looking at that
you're actually looking at it
everybody's worried about impressions
how many people saw it I don't care how
many people saw it I care how many
people saw it I care to see it and
actually consumed it and that had the
intent to act on it I'd much rather have
three customers paying me a million
dollars than 50,000 potential customers
paying zero and so that's what snapchat
does it forces you to pay attention you
actually have to hold down the button
and see it and then it disappears unlike
Facebook and Twitter where that content
may show up again